all right buckle up this is a busy news
night now we start with crushing blows
for the radical left in the destroyed
Trump media and according to reports the
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
has told the president last Thursday he
is not a target in the Muller Russia
probe or in the separate investigation
into the president's personal attorney
Michael Kohn now rod Rosenstein
reportedly voluntarily shared that
information with the president during
this meeting at the White House last
Thursday and this comes after president
Trump shot down wild rumors and
speculation that he will fire
Robert Muller and rod Rosenstein this
has been going on for months these
developments are good news for the
president and a major setback for the
conspiratorial media and liberal
Democrats in this country for over a
year they have been saying that there is
major bombshell evidence of Trump Russia
collusion one problem it doesn't exist
and that's confirmed in force tonight
it's all been one big giant farce total
fabrication conspiracy theory designed
to smear and undermine and D legitimize
the President of the United States and
as we are now seeing tonight it
continues to fall apart now another key
development we're following tonight the
president is now adding some very
serious firepower to his legal team
former New York City Mayor former
federal prosecutor Rudy Giuliani and two
other key attorneys have just been added
now Rudy Giuliani told The Washington
Post that he is coming aboard because he
hopes to quote negotiate an end to the
Russian probe for the good of the
country I say Amen because the American
people all of you deserve better than
this it's a crucial move because as
we've been telling you robert muller his
merrie team of democratic donors they
need to stop this ever-expanding
insanity Russian collusion now has
become and evolved into stormy Daniels
this madness has to end and also tonight
the former FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe he is in some serious legal
trouble
the DOJ Inspector General has issued a
criminal referral for McCabe after
finding that he lied under oath three
times in an investigation about media
leaks Jim Comey are you paying a 10
you know even though the evidence
against him is overwhelming
McCabe's legal team is firing back with
a statement the reads quote we are
advised of within of the referral within
the past few weeks although we believe
the referral is unjustified the standard
for an IG referral is very low and we
have already met with staff members from
the US Attorney's office and we are
confident unless there is inappropriate
pressure from high levels of the
administration the US Attorney's Office
will conclude that it should decline to
prosecute here's the problem with that
statement
the investigation into McCabe had
nothing to do with President Trump this
is the DOJ Inspector General his name is
Michael Horowitz get used to that name
because you're going to hear a lot about
it in the next few weeks he
independently reached the conclusion
about McCabe lying and he was appointed
by President Obama and this part is key
becames old boss and his friend James
Comey he's now admitting that he is the
one that kick-started the entire probe
against Andrew McCabe not Donald Trump
no Comey is also saying that he could
end up being a witness in a possible
criminal case against Andrew McCabe his
number two at the FBI look at this if
they ultimately bring a case against
Andrew McCain would you be a witness for
the prosecution potentially I don't know
whether the reporting is accurate I know
it's CNN reporting but I don't know it
of my own accord but sure
given that the IGS report reflects
interactions that Andy McCabe had with
me and other FBI senior executives I
could well be a witness
looks like McCabe is clearly challenged
Annalee as enter Hillary Clinton and
pretending like there's some vast
right-wing conspiracy out to get this
guy but it was his home friend his boss
his number one he was number two James
Comey he's not sticking by him now
president Trump is weighing in on this
on Twitter he said James Comey just
through Andrew McCabe under the bus
inspector general's report oma came as a
disaster for both of them
getting a little lot of their own
medicine and speaking of hillary clinton
McCabe's growing legal exposure this
could be a very bad sign for her and
other obama deep state actors now as we
explained last night nearly a dozen GOP
lawmakers they
said a criminal referral to the DOJ and
the FBI demanding investigations into
possible crimes committed by Clinton
James Comey Andrew McCabe Loretta Lynch
Peter struck Lisa page and other Obama
era officials is a massive story now
take a look at the side of your screen
these are the criminal charges that they
are recommending for just James Comey
and they sent the letter to the FBI the
DOJ and US attorney John Hoover laying
out a pretty damning case against the
former FBI director as we warned him
don't write the book and don't go on a
book tour they explained how Comey fixed
the Clinton email investigation again
remember how long we've been telling you
exoneration before interviewing Hillary
Clinton and 17 other key witnesses it
doesn't work that way and these
lawmakers lay out how Comey gave
conflicting testimony under oath
possibly even committing perjury and
admitted to having a friend leaked the
information about his memos to the New
York Times which in light of the coma
memos just released he says oh I'm not
sneaky I'm not a leaker well he admitted
that he leaked and the lawmakers are
also referring criminal charges for
Hillary Clinton over the scheme that she
used what funneling over 12 million
dollars to Fuzion GPS through a law firm
Perkins cuy that then hired a foreign
national
remember foreign nationals are bad not
supposed to influence our elections
Christopher Steele and he's the one that
used and created the unverified
uncorroborated dossier that was full of
Russia and Russian government lies and
propaganda all in an effort to mislead
you the American people in the lead-up
to an election now criminal charges are
also being recommended by these
lawmakers perform at Attorney General
Loretta Lynch threatening the Iranian
one informant he was on this show with
reprisal anti-trump FBI lovers struck at
Lisa Paige they're also being referred
for criminal charges
now this congressional letter is also
asking Andrew McCabe and other Obama
deep state officials those involved in
the dossier be investigated for possible
criminal conduct and finally tonight
James commis media circus is now turning
into what is an unmitigated disaster
there for the disgraced former FBI
director just this weekend Comey was
trashing President Trump to Clinton's
sycophant BFF George Stephanopoulos
remember this you write the president
Trump is unethical untethered to the
truth is Donald Trump unfit to be
President
yes but not in the way I often hear
people talk about it I don't buy this
stuff about him being financially
incompetent - early stages of dementia
he strikes me as a person of
above-average intelligence who's
tracking conversations and knows what's
going on I don't think he's medically
unfit to be President I think he's
morally unfit to be President a person
who sees moral equivalence in
charlottesville who talks about and
treats women like they're pieces of meat
who lies constantly about matters big
and small and insist the American people
believe it
that person's not fit to be President
the United States so after being called
out for taking those petty cheap shots
all come me call me all of a sudden yeah
oh he's beginning to change his tune
take a look you write that your
experience in high school gave you a
quote lifelong hatred for bullies do you
do you think President Trump is a bully
and do you hate him I definitely don't
hate him there are things he does that
make me uncomfortable I think are
inappropriate that are in some ways like
a bully like behavior but I don't hate
Donald Trump I don't even dislike Donald
Trump all right so Comey can't seem to
make his mind up now the guy spent the
past year slamming president Trump
including mocking his appearance and
every way imaginable and now we're
supposed to believe that Comey when he
tells us that oh he doesn't hate the
president do you think we're that dumb
it is a massive contradiction for James
Comey but it's not the only confounding
answer this guy is giving here's Comey
claiming that he's never been asked of
Hillary Clinton obstructed justice in
her email case during a radio interview
on WTOP in DC this is unbelievable take
a listen
why wouldn't mashing of cellphones and
the destruction of thousands of emails
during an investigation clearly be
obstruction of justice
that's a great question that's the first
time we've been asked that and and the
answer is it would depend upon what the
intent of the people doing it was lots
of people smash their cell phones so
they're not resold on the secondary
market and your personal stuff ends up
in somebody else's hands but if you
smash your cell phone
knowing that investigators want it and
that they've got a subpoena for it for
example that
a different thing and can be obstruction
of justice the law requires intent yes
it requires not just intent but the
prosecutors demonstrate corrupt intent
all right seriously he was never asked
if Clinton and her team obstructed
justice really okay try this subpoenaed
emails subpoenaed okay imagine then if
we have to worry about intent after the
subpoena you delete 33,000 emails you
use acid wash bleach pitch with most
Americans have never heard about then
someone on your team smashes your mobile
devices with a hammer seriously
after the subpoena there's no intent
good luck to any of you that try that
with any court or any prosecutor in the
country I don't think it's going to work
out well now Comey is either totally and
completely incompetent or you must think
we're fools now this is why so many
people have been calling for an unbiased
investigation into what Hillary Clinton
has done here
do we have equal justice under the law
equal application under the laws are we
a constitutional republic